good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is scp-1472 object
class safe special containment
procedures a three meter tall chain-link
privacy fence is to be constructed
around the property boundary of scp-1472
construction signage is to be placed on
all sides of the perimeter fence as to
deter public suspicion mobile task force
iota six also known as hard knocks are
tasked with protecting the site from
trespassers and are to be stationed
within a four-block quadrant around
scp-1472 and all times
dressed in applicable urban attire any
civilians that breach the fence are to
be apprehended and be administered Class
A amnestics before being released any
testing involving d-class resources must
have level three approval all d-class
personnel involved with testing are to
be interrogated via polygraph afterwards
description scp-1472 is a brightly
painted single-story brick building
located in East San Louis Illinois USA
on the corner of straight and Avenue the
exterior condition of the building is
poor but it remains stable city records
indicate that the building was erected
in 1978 by the now-defunct Corporation
scp-1472 has been condemned since 2001
when scp-1472 s anomalous activity began
scp-1472 has only one accessible
entrance on the west side of the
building when entered during its
inactive state scp-1472 appears
completely empty scp-1472 only becomes
active every Saturday at 2:00 a.m.
during this active state and overweight
human male scp-1472 1 while
exit from scp-1472 and display signage
out in front of the entrance one display
is set directly on the asphalt in front
of the entrance which lists a schedule
of events the other larger display is
placed directly on the sign of the
building and lit with decorative neon
lighting notes scp-1472 signage text on
the 1st of December 2013 exotic girls
are equivalent during the active period
scp-1472 one will insist that all
persons seeking admittance pant cover
charge of dollars and not engage in
photography or video recording once
inside shows will differ nightly however
the performance is always range from 2
a.m. to 3:30 a.m. during the duration of
the performances the entrance or exit
will remain mocked until the last show
ends injuries and fatalities have
occurred depending on the content of the
show participants have been observed to
sustain psychological trauma test log 14
72 0 1 1 2 1 3 4 preamble 3 d-class
subjects were approved for testing on
the 1st of December 2013 d-class test
subjects were transported to the site
and told to wait in front to the
entrance of scp-1472 d-class test
subjects were told that they must take
notes and report everything that they
see inside below was a schedule of
events as posted outside of scp-1472
before testing schedule of shows 2 2 to
10 admittance 210 to 215 the Kumbha sh
sisters 215 to 220 Helen Keller 220 to
230 the fantastic zippy and trainer
to 32 to 35 teeth and claw marks to 35
to 240 intermission to 42 to 41 erotic
performance exe to 41 to 245 the Council
of libidinous elders to 45 to 320 serial
number 20 to 30 to 44 on 9p 320 to 330
indecipherable cuneiform script D class
ID d 34 32 d 6744 and d 99 oh wait 1:50
a.m. d-class test subjects were dropped
off by transport and were told to
approach scp-1472 s entrance each were
given a hundred dollars in five-dollar
bills
d-class test subjects are also
encouraged to spend their money once
inside 1:55 a.m. scp-1472 one emerged
from the entrance with signage scp-1472
one began to set up around the entrance
d-class test subjects and scp-1472 one
did not interact with each other
- am scp-1472 one allowed admittance
into scp-1472 scp-1472 one asked from
each d-class test subject dollars as a
cover charge d-class test subjects
obliged and paid set cover charge in
exchange for admission into scp-1472 203
am
I'll D class subjects were now inside a
CP 1472 d-class test subjects reported
that the interior conditions were
excellent the interior was outfitted
with shag carpeting mirrored walls a
single disco ball which hung from the
ceiling a thick fabric curtain that
covered most of the stage and a single
brass pole which extended from the
ceiling down into the middle of the room
comfortable seating arrangements were
made available for a maximum occupancy
of 30 - 10 a.m. to 2:15 a.m. the Kuhn
bish sisters the curtain opened to
reveal two naked women sitting on a
wooden log the women appeared to be
twins of Asian descent both women then
performed traditional Tuvan
throat-singing while massaging each
other for the duration of the show the
3432 and d90 908 deposited $10 on stage
which prompted the women to pause and
begin a faster song the curtain then
closed at the end of the show 2:15 a.m.
to 2:20 a.m. Helen Keller the curtain
opened to reveal a woman with the same
physical appearance as Helen Keller in
her mid-20s the woman was dressed in
typical Las Vegas showgirl attire and
began to perform a dance routine onstage
while undressing at the same time D 3432
D 6744 and D 90 908 each deposited ten
dollars on stage this prompted the woman
to immediately interrupt her routine and
recite poetry for a few seconds
these 6744 deposited another five
dollars on stage with the same results
the curtain then closed at the end of
the show 2:20 a.m. to 2:30 a.m.
the fantastic zippy and trainer the
curtain opened to reveal an orangutan
sitting on a metal stool next to a
headless woman with advanced necrotizing
fasciitis
despite being headless the woman was
able to function normally the orangutan
then began to give vocal commands
directed at the woman to which she
responded by performing a pole dancing
routine the 3432 deposited $5 on the
floor next to the woman the woman
responded by pushing the $5 bill
directly into her exposed trachea the
orangutan then ordered the woman back to
the stage the curtain then closed at the
end of the show 2:30 a.m. to 2:35 a.m.
teeth and claw marks the curtain opened
to reveal for predatory bipedal reptiles
based on the d-class test subjects
descriptions the reptiles may have
belonged to the genus velociraptor each
were dressed in a Japanese maid cosplay
costume tailored to fit them the
reptiles began to approach d90 908 off
stage in an extremely aggressive manner
d90 908 relinquished all of his money
which seemed to appease the reptiles as
they collected the money and shifted
attention to warrants d-34 32 d-34 32
also relinquished all of his money with
his same results afterwards
all four reptiles were ordered back on
stage by a CP 1472 one and the curtain
then closed d 6744
divided the remainder of his money with
the other d-class test subjects
2:35 a.m. to 2:40 a.m. intermission no
events were reported during this time
2:40 a.m. to 241 a.m. erotic performance
Exe the curtain opened to reveal a
gateway 2000 computer and a monitor
running a finestra 98 operating system
the display booted up and opened a
program on its desktop the computer then
began to rapidly recite a multitude of
differential equations as well as their
respective 3d graphical representations
for 20 seconds at the end of the program
the monitor displayed the word insert in
the form of a screensaver d 6744
and d 3432 both inserted five dollars
into its floppy drive the curtain then
closed at the end of the show 241 a.m.
to 2:45 a.m. the Council of libidinous
elders the curtain opened to reveal 16
entities levitating above the stage each
entity appeared as a translucent
gelatinous mass filled with membranous
tissues the entities then began to
project transmissions via telepathy into
the minds of the d-class test subjects
d-class test subjects reported migraines
acute tinnitus and projected thoughts of
intense physical sensation no money was
deposited on the stage the curtain then
closed at the end of the show 2:45 a.m.
to 3:20 a.m. serial number twenty to
thirty to forty 409 P the curtain opened
to reveal a pair of mechanical humanoid
legs running in place the apparatus was
being powered by an internal combustion
generator situated on the left side of
the stage scp-1472 one was seen pouring
a substance into the generator by funnel
based on the d-class test subjects
descriptions of appearance and odor this
substance is believed to possibly be raw
ambergris
after 15 minutes d90 908 deposited five
dollars on stage the apparatus then
began to perform a traditional Irish
step dancing routine scp-1472 one then
brought out a plastic tray filled with
an unknown species of beetle and placed
the apparatus atop them the apparatus
continued to dance for the duration of
the show while scp-1472 one periodically
replaced the trays with refilled ones
the aroma produced by the performance
was reported to be orally pungent to the
point of nausea the curtain enclosed at
the end of the show 3:20 a.m. to 3:30
a.m. indecipherable cuneiform script the
curtain opened to reveal scp-1093
wearing a small mawashi and holding an
ornate stone blade after a minute
scp-1093 lunged at d 3432 after a brief
altercation scp-1093 was able to render
d 3432 unconscious and move his body
towards the stage based on reports by
the d-class test subjects scp-1093 then
began to perform a ritual human
sacrifice the 6744 attempted to rescue d
3432 but was halted by a CP 1472 won and
was warned that he was not allowed to
touch the dancers scp-1093 then
proceeded to remove all major organs
from D 3432 in order of size before
kicking them off stage this lasted for
the remainder of the show note
Foundation Records confirmed that
scp-1093 was secured in its containment
unit during this time period which
suggests that this was a physically
identical yet extremely violent instance
of scp-1093 it is also believed that
during the performance scp-1093 was only
producing roughly 4% of its normal
radioactive emissions since the 6744
and d 90 908 survived with moderate
radiation poisoning after the show ended
3:32 am scp-1472 one was observed
standing outside smoking a large cigar
as the surviving d-class subjects
staggered out of scp-1472 d 6744 and d
90 908 were apprehended and taken to the
infirmary scp-1472 one was then observed
removing the signs and retreating back
to scp-1472 be 3432 s remains were never
recovered
[Music]
ok I think that about does it for today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to research her Brandon Connell
Burlington the cop slump god Justin day
Pierce M Hamlin white crew beware 600
Bryson Billy my archive trader Nick
diver bull Cody tench cheese whip the
Android the administrator quartz 5 6 3
on tree hero if you would like a special
thank you at the end of each of my
videos on some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you